[Musik]
bei wohligen blog gesehen hat als christ
nicht dort ein tattoo bekommen habe und
leute was ist da dran also scheint
zumindest ein wenig kombiniert haben ist
unglaublich
gegen die 26 grad die höchsttemperatur
heute soll bei 35 grad sich aufhalten
wird
mehr freiheit mehr denn je findet das
einzigartige er gibt leute die haben
radierer und den benötigen drauf und da
sind nicht nur kemper wäre ich wollte
heute die nachbarskinder wiedersehen
werden weil der block vorgestern kam
relativ gut bei euch an und daran die
chinesen bisschen gegen uns gemacht und
uns beleidigt kriegt eine oma in
arschloch war weil ganz andere frage
jetzt am rande immer wieder bock auf dem
depot bei weil ich habe hier unten china
das für waschmittel also wenig
waschmittel habe ich habe hier noch ein
halte er ist 100 markt hier inhalte
gelegt da noch eine ältere gopro hero
wir einfach und ich hab noch nirgendwo
also wenn ihr bock habt das nicht das
vielleicht bei dem nächsten blog dass
wir verlosen last man leichter
ich habe gerade
[Musik]
egal was der täter deutlich welche meine
katze wieder gefunden ich möchte ihn
gestellt ich bekomme laptop der welt
wieder kommentare oder die ganzen
geschenke sind die bei den zentren für
in wien und im bauch bekommen habe die
habe ich alle verbrannt weil wir warten
[Musik]
noch nicht alles bei mir angekommen der
postbank wirklich sinn 34 riesige kiste
voll mit geschenken und natürlich ist
wieder cool dass ich so viel bekommen
aber aber ihr müsst verstehen dass das
ein sehr großer logistischer aufwand ist
dass ich das irgendwie hinbekommen aber
keine werke wobei die waren hier sind
werde ich auf jeden fall instagram
leistung zu machen
erfreuliches jahr weiter voll aber werde
ich mir immer ist das hier
die grad schon gesehen das habe ich mir
das essen warm gemacht was ich je
gegessen habe und wir probieren es mit
immer noch schleichen will hier
überhaupt nicht wie irgendwelche
produkte werben oder irgendwelche fluges
in dem fall aber auch mir spaß macht hat
man kauft euch mal so in der woche
weitere 23
die qualität einfach früchte kuriert und
wir sind einfach die termine in den
wäldern aufgefallen seitdem ich jetzt
wochen lang jeden morgen eröffnung
getränke das nicht einfach nicht mehr
krank werde so einfach sein
sie bemüht und köpfe dieser moment in
dem viele aus meiner wohnung eine
wanderin dem müll weil ich bin hier
beginnt jetzt auf dem weg die jahner und
wir haben schon gerade entdeckt dass ich
immer im auto kofferraum noch eine
wasserpistole aber dass wir die jungs
wieder treffen gibt auf jeden fall creek
[Musik]
ihr vielleicht gesehen hat waren machte
sich gestern trainieren und eine
richtige korrekt ernährung ist von
großer bedeutung
das betreute denken leicht alles
wir stellen uns einfach so oft nach
hause präsentiert jedes überlegte
lieferservices patente nicht überlegt
[Musik]
jana hat ein glaskinn als auch marc
candidate mit dazu
[Musik]
ok ich komme nach unten die läuft gegen
die exekution hp drucker besitzt da muss
irgendwie auf fünf jahre
jetzt haben die letzten stunden 10.000
würde
bisher gehört am angeln luca im pool was
gefunden okay halt gar nicht
ach was im video das den dienst
meistereien er braucht man wirklich
nicht firma hat wohl gefunden handy mit
windows shop.de erfreulich
wir sitzen jetzt schon weil viele briten
[Musik]
shop.de wenn jetzt eine challenge machen
die ja natürlich überlegt hat und wie
jana pinka mit dem ersten sprung
harmonie tritt an
[Musik]
eigentlich mag macht den nächsten sprung
ein guter sprung
[Musik]
die my name
bei der nächsten stelle weiterlesen
shell und gucken wir wer länger die luft
anhalten kann
wir sind jetzt schon ein bisschen länger
hier wieder im pool also ich bin jetzt
schon so weit dass irgendwie wasser
unter der linde weitere euch gerade
fragt wieso meine kamera so komisch
aussieht und so komisch verschwommen ja
die ist glaube ich gerade durch das was
er kaputt gehören der menschen befolgt
die wir weitergeben wollten und ihr weg
bringt auch nicht wenn ich da irgendwie
drüber wird irgendwie so es ist einfach
gerade befinden
ich glaube ich begreife den tag über mit
meinem iphone werden die kamera jetzt
gerade noch für kurze zeit im
kühlschrank weil einige auf meinten das
zusatz was bringen würde aber noch nicht
besser geworden was sind jetzt auf dem
rückweg von jana und fahren nach köln
auf den weg dahin fahren wir noch beim
open-air weil ich mir noch einen eigenen
pool kaufen wollte aber jetzt seinen
eigenen kunden können wir dann kaufte ob
sein machen machen wir bald wir sind
immobilien gekommen wir haben den pool
gefunden das ist keine platzierung ringe
marke aber einfach nur einmal 180 und
meine terrasse ist glaube ich was hat
nie gewehrt aber mit der sehr genau das
perfekte frau meint es wäre gut wenn wir
eine plane untendrunter legen und mit
planen abdecken des begehrten
bauzeichnungen schwester haben verzollen
gekauft 35 euro dann haben wir das hier
30 euro das heißt es nur ums alter
brauchen die wette zu 80 euro
wer mittwoch kein pool gekauft weil der
pool irgendwie 80 euro dann alles
zusammen kostet hat und mit der pflege
wird als auch irgendwie gewesen aber
machen ich habe mit jeweils und wird die
last die kameras immer noch kaputt luca
wie gesagt sind wir jetzt wieder frau
sage communication das was jetzt gerade
die high von sieben plus qualität ist
und deshalb packen können glaub ich will
mit meiner kamera filmt die kamera jetzt
noch einen kühlschrank gepackt und 15
minuten gestellt
deutlich dass die kamera aus dem touch
funktionieren kann traut sich diktiert
also auch den anklopft und er die
fähigkeit habe ich jetzt komplett kaputt
hier ist der akku ich studiere jetzt
nochmal rein macht das ganze zu und
leute ich drücke ich hab den sieht
leider immer noch so aus also auch wenn
ich hier immer wieder mit dem polit
oberfläche das verändert sich kein
küsschen
nach dieser momente menschen eine
klimaanlage
das sind richtig wirklich immer für ein
südafrika zielgruppen kann und sagt
zwischen braunschweig und wolfsburg
die angepackt dann ist das schlimmste
lux
ich bin jetzt zum training wieder zu
hause bist du schon eine kleinigkeit
gegessen und sogar schon ein bisschen an
der kamera versucht herumzuschrauben
sachsen sogar auch noch für kurze zeit
den kühlschrank gepackt aber so sah er
dabei geblieben dass da immer noch von
bissing kondenswasser unter der linse
und jetzt habe ich sie hat einfach
unseren gefäß mit reis gepackt dass ich
neben kommen die abhol und reparieren
wenn auch ganz gefallen habe ich mich
über nike rollen und der venus morgen in
einer video wieder schön
kleines update dominierten morgens
meiner kamera sind wirklich funktioniert
mit dem reis also wenn unter eurer linse
und einem handy oder bei der kamera
irgendwann mal wasser reise sollte
einfach packen und paar stunden warten